um so for you like fast forward now
having that kind of happen and having
people kind of come into your catalog
and check out like the newer [__] like
where are you on the music side because
you're so you're doing so much you're
obviously Community leader you're
obviously doing the uh podcast and still
dropping new music how do you balance
the [__] balance yeah
um
honestly it's the same [__] so uh
with our uh Studio we have a studio
where we film our podcast we also got a
recording studio there if you get what
I'm saying so and then it's like I was
popping away with the music way before
the podcast and [__] I just started
doing the podcast and [__] because my
team shout out talker media shout out
bear Jones they was like bro you going
on all these people platforms and you're
blowing that [__] up like people love to
hear you talk right bro start doing your
own [__] right and they was telling me
this for damn near a year or two before
I said [__] it come on let's try it and
then one day we did it in front of the
first episode people gravitated towards
it and then I had um the people that
reach out like bro I want to come on
your podcast I want to sit down with you
when you sitting at your house at four
in the morning and Marshawn Lynch call
you and like bro what the [__] bro why
you ain't telling me you had a podcast
he just talked he just came on the
second time right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he just did it a second time and
it's just like you know people like that
and just talk like bro I rather sit down
with you because [__] [__] you fed a
call you're the culture right [__] you
ain't trying to make no money you ain't
vulture you ain't asking no weird ass
questions you not I'm you're not gonna
have a blood on your podcast or asking
why they Funk with Crips you know you
get what I'm saying like that [__] just
sterile so I'm like [__] I might as well
keep this [__] going so that's what made
me just drop that [__] and low and push
the [__] out the podcast yeah well how
often do you drop is it once a week
um no sometimes it depends like
um sometimes I drop three or four a week
it depends sometimes I won't drop
nothing for two weeks it depends on how
we feeling so
um it been days to wear in the garden
did eight interviews and one day got
there got to our uh Studio probably
before and we ain't leaving the three or
four in the morning type [__] and then
waking up and being back there at 12
again like you know I feel like too it
was like a needed uh void filled in the
bay yeah to have like a dope platform
obviously I think if you come to La you
got guys like 80 and T well doing their
thing right you know shout out uh Tyrell
he put me on a no jumper salute t-real
for that I remember that interview yeah
that was one of the early uh t-rell
interviews yeah um no honestly it was
the last interview they did in that day
before they left oh in the old building
though it was in the old building yeah
yeah shout out to real for that and like
I said uh Tyrell was on there early you
know all his homies I [__] with LA a lot
like bro you gotta get blood on your
[__] you gotta get blood on your [__]
you interviewing all these [__] like
you gotta get blood on your [__] like
you know blood really he really pushed
this [__] and when rap about he really
is that so grab him on your [__] and
when he reached out you know it's all
salute to t-rev he did it I just think
it's dope too because like you always
will hear that like the bay doesn't get
enough credit and that's true in terms
of influence in terms of culture in
terms of just everything that they've
brought to the game
and me and gazi always have these
conversations about like how back in the
day there was so much music industry
in San Francisco in the Bay Area you had
Jive Records Was there and you had a lot
of a lot of people would have offices
around the city and I guess like what's
kind of missing is like representation
of media right on a bigger scale right
right
um so I think it's dope to like you saw
that like hey I'ma just do this [__]
myself you know definitely and uh like I
said with my [__] um
like I just feel like my [__] is is
authentic bro like my [__] is pure like
I don't get people on my [__] and ask
trying to stir [__] out start [__] I'm
not looking for no viral moment right
like I always tell people all the time
my viral moment is well we sit in there
building and we having a conversation
and you may say some [__] that somebody
is going through you get what I'm saying
and that might spark a flame in them to
change their life or they probably was
thinking about suicide and they didn't
commit suicide because they looking at
okay damn if little blood going through
this [__] you feel me and this is how
you handle it I can get over this [__]
too so that's my final moment I ain't
looking for no click bait we don't do
click bait we don't do none of that [__]
I might drop an interview and the [__]
don't do no numbers you feel me but the
shorter take off right yeah yes for sure
the real shorter yeah so all right I'm
doing my job bro like I said I'm not on
that fake [__] we don't do that at
talking media we don't
um push [__] we you know we
articulture and we're not trying to gain
off the culture and we're not trying to
exploit the culture you get what I'm
saying for sure man I think I I that's
why I think I told I think uh one of the
like I think the Russell interview I saw
you do was just incredible I was like
this [__] is dope thank you Marshawn
[__] is though I didn't see the new
Marshawn
um interview but obviously we just
filmed it we haven't dropped the [__]
it'd be very hard for anybody to get the
Marshawn Lynch interview you got for
sure man this other one the second one
like I said that's like
um that was brother you know at the end
of the day uh you know we help each
other like from the fam first shout out
fam first shout out Josh Johnson shout
out Marcus Peters shout out all them
guys over there first it's like a family
thing you know I'm I'm doing um
fundraisers I'm helping them uh with
talent shows or you know whatever it is
maybe what date doing I'm in full
support of it so whatever I do they are
in full support of it and it's all the
way love type [__]